zach is with us axon Arizona hi Zach how
are you hey Dave are you doing better
than I deserve what's up hey so me and
my wife have been working our behinds
off the past four or five years pan off
crazy debt and we're actually doing real
good right now we're at about baby step
five six great um she's got a she shot
about two three hundred thousand dollars
in stock that she gets as her bonus Wow
and we were trying to figure out what to
do with it I got a kid that's in high
school right now and we're thinking
about college and stuff like that but
this this this stock that's out there
we're worried that if the stock price
goes down that we're gonna lose a
boatload of money yeah so we leave that
stock where it's at no so what are you
gonna do with it are you gonna use it
for college two or three hundred
thousand three hundred thousand dollars
that's a lot of money for college I was
thinking uh how much do you owe on your
house no so we're pretty much 100%
debt-free we owe eighty on the house
yeah how about you know credit card debt
okay so you owe eighty on the house but
your household income is what Oh between
200 and 250 a year okay and you have
zero debt other than 80-thousand on your
house none of any kind right we just saw
well I have my six years left on my
legacy plan which is child support for
my son okay but that's not a dad you
just have to pay child support
okay yeah and what else you have any
debt know where your we have three to
four hundred thousand and a 401k plan
not you how about fifteen thousand an
emergency fault yeah how old are you
we're 43 what's the house worth 250 good
well you're in really good shape
and you have a 17 year old and what
other kids do you have that you're going
to pay for college no I have a 14 year
old he's a freshman in high school oh
okay you only want so you have one son
College to pay for okay yes so here's an
interesting exercise number one what I
do today is I'd cash out the stock the
first thing I would do with it is I pay
off your house now you're a 100 percent
debt-free you're on a budget making two
hundred fifty thousand dollars a year
you can probably cash flow most places
he would go to college but you've got
another two hundred thousand left over
or another hundred and fifty thousand
left over after you pay off your house
to do other stuff with right so you can
start indexing for college aggressively
and you can have a big pile of money for
college in addition to you know a great
income and you'll have a tremendous
amount of wealth because you you make
ten fifty thousand dollars a year in the
next five years you know you're gonna
make a million and a half before this
kid goes to college so you're gonna be
able to send the kid to college right
without any trouble but we've got to be
intentional we have to be careful to do
it but you make plenty of money to
mathematically to do it without any
trouble now so then the second thing I
would do after first things cash out the
stocks second thing is I'd pay off the
house the third thing is I would sit
down and start to look at actual schools
now it won't be the same cost today as
it is five years from now but just go
and say where do we think jr. might go
to school and let's look at what they
cost right so we've he's going to a
community college for the first part he
get scholarships tuitions free because
he's a local in the area uh-huh and then
he's more than likely in a trust for the
Texas Tech just finish it out okay or if
he wants to go to Texas Tech for four
years you've got the money right and I'm
splitting the money with splitting the
bill with my with his mom yeah even even
if you pay for it and she you know even
if she can't pay for it you just pay for
it you've got the money you're fine so
yeah you know you got two hundred fifty
thousand bucks we take eighty thousand
dollars out we pay for pay off the house
that leaves 150 thousand dollars that we
can earmark for with this and other
wealth building and then you go to Texas
Tech's website you figure out what it
costs there whatever the tuition is my
guess is is probably around ten to
twelve thirteen thousand bucks a year
right now something like that it's about
double that for housing roughly okay
so if it's if you have $13,000 tuition
you're probably a twenty six thousand a
year times four is a hundred thousand
bucks you know so if you take a hundred
thousand bucks and you set it aside this
kid goes to school for in set aside a
hundred thousand dollars a year market
in your mind and a mutual fund growing
this kid will go to Texas Tech and you
can pay a hundred percent of it all four
years including housing now that's
assuming my numbers are right but I mean
you see what I'm doing so the third step
after you paid off your house if you
first steps cash the stock out second
step pay off the house third step is
actually study Texas Tech find out what
it actually costs I find out what it
costs to live there while he's going to
school and go ahead and lay a budget out
for four years an earmark that much
money and set it aside and you can check
that box it's done now you just move on
with your income right right and so if
it's a hundred hundred fifty thousand
bucks and you set that in a mutual fund
even if it's not in the kids name even
if it's not technically a college fund
it's just your mutual fund and you said
we're not touching this this is the
college fund you're done you can check
that box ur over okay and then that's
what I'm talking about we gave we you
said there's 250 I used 80 that only
leaves 175 you're gonna use most of that
175 for Texas Tech for four years
including housing effect and I'm gonna
go ahead and set that aside now okay now
now you don't have to save anything else
for college ever you make $250,000 a
year you don't have a payment in the
world now you go about the business of
becoming very very wealthy and
outrageously generous as you go along
the college has done your retirement is
well underway you're fine with your
retirement keep adding to it of course
max it out and now you start investing
and and you increase your generosity
factor and and you know so here's my
prediction if you stay on this track and
you stay out of debt and you stay on a
written plan a detailed plan where you
make your money behave you're 43 now in
21 years you're gonna be worth in the
neighborhood of 10 million dollars
that's where you'll be at 64 years old
but you make $250,000 dude you ought to
be okay now most people make turn
$50,000 to blow it all and they don't
have anything but you ought to be so
you're gonna change your family tree if
you stay on track I'll prove it to you
I'm gonna send you a copy of the book
every day millionaires and it'll outline
exactly what I just showed you and Chris
Hogan wrote this book is from the study
of the largest study of millionaires
ever done in North America every day
maybe there's so long since your copy